okay is it a crutch hurricane at this
man it might as well be like an
ergonomic crutch cane like a bionic man
I feel a little Bionic
it's amazing what this brace does you
know it's wild
I can technically like put a little bit
of weight on it which it's amazing how
are you feeling is it painful you on
meds what's happening I'm not on meds
my try and try to stay away from the
painkillers until I need to sleep and
it's it's painful at times but right now
it's not I mean having in this
environment your body's like nothing
hurts I'm fine and you're not hi
yeah I'm sure halfway through the film
I'll be sitting in my chair at a weird
angle and being like oh has it affected
filming at all cuz you're our he man No
are you filming that now not right now
now we have to ask you are you going to
attempt another shower livestream I
don't think so because one will never be
as enjoyable as that one was ever again
this movie is so amazing we can't wait
to see you in it how great are these
women incredible oh my god personally
knowing them developing that you know
the relationship that we have when we
were all working together they are such
a family in such a strong group of women
and it comes through on screen last
question where's your date my date not
here how is she your angel miss Alexis
well she's in Tahiti right now she's
raising money and awareness for coral
she's an angel in your life the angel
[Music]